vasseur bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous ce matin en direct sur rt france
alors le rapport que vient de publier le
giec est-il alarmistes ou juste réaliste
selon vous alors oui je dirais pas qu'il
est alarmiste mais alarmant encore plus
alarmant que les rapports précédents
mais il n'y a pas il n'ya rien
d'alarmiste en fait les trajectoires que
notre le giec finalement se confirmer
les derniers rapports du giec a indiqué
des trajectoires pour notre période qui
se sont confirmées donc non je dirais un
rapport de plus en plus alarmants donc
c'est pire et plus vite qu'on le
craignait
ce réchauffement climatique
effectivement là ce que le un des
éléments peut-être du rapport ce qu'il
en dit que c'est que là le réchauffement
climatique donc l'accord de paris avait
donné un objectif de réduction de
rupture de stock du réchauffement
climatique a intrigué le 5° est là en
fait ce dernier rapport indique que
cette on est sur une trajectoire où en
fait on atteindrait un niveau de
réchauffement climatique 2,5 degrés
d'ici 2030 tandis que normalement ça
aurait dû être 2040
et c'est même l'objectif d' arrêt de
l'augmentation du réchauffement
climatique alors en cette la coop 26
doit se tenir en novembre prochain à
glasgow en écosse alors emmanuel macron
a aussitôt réagi il a appelé à trouver
un accord à la hauteur de l'urgence
emmanuel macron qui avait fait de
l'écologie son cheval de bataille où on
est on aujourd'hui en france justement
de ce combat pour l'écologie
eh bien je dirais que le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron emmanuel macron lui-même
son sont très forts pour faire des
effets d'annoncé comme comme on peut le
voir là avec avec cet appel à avoir un
grand accord lors de la cop vantis mais
le gouvernement lui même ne respecte pas
finalement les engagements qu'il était
censé avoir pris dans le cadre des
accords de paris
et donc on est vraiment dans une
situation où on a un président qui joue
beaucoup sur la communication qui avait
lancé son mandat avec l'idée qu'il
fallait games qui est capable de d'avoir
de vrais effet d'annonce mais finalement
dans les faits au niveau des actes les
dernières lois qui ont été passées ne
permettent pas d'être sur la trajectoire
de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de 40% et même au niveau
européen ça a été réhaussée jusque -55%
hélas par rapport à ça on en est très
loin
justement vous paris mais que ça soit
aussi également bruxelles ou berlin tous
sont donc appelés à réagir rapidement
pour enfin voilà pour qu'on se retrouve
pas non on ne voit pas en tout cas
d'autres dégâts puisque on voit déjà
beaucoup de canicule et d'un sens dire
également des inondations dans le monde
vous l'avez dit vous l'avez souvenir des
belles paroles mais les actes suivent
pas pourquoi justement le gouvernement
ne tient pas ses promesses
eh bien je pense que à l'échelle de la
france n'a ménagé l'international il ya
d'une certaine manière un manque de
volonté politique
c'est à dire que là il ya la sortie du
rapport du giec et on a l'ensemble des
gouvernements qui réagissent en disant
qu'il faudrait un accord à la hauteur de
l'ambition pour la coop 26 en réalité
c'est décrit vision que les
gouvernements connaissez c'est des
prévisions qui étaient déjà indiqué
qu'ils sont pire que ce qui était le cas
mais les gouvernements sont informés de
ce genre de choses est ce qui manque
c'est une vraie volonté politique
effectivement réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et mener des
politiques qui soient à la hauteur de
l'enjeu et qui effectivement vont à
l'encontre de certains enjeux
économiques tandis qu'on voit que par
exemple parler de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat a précédé
précédemment les lobbys était
extrêmement présents pour défendre leurs
intérêts auprès des 150 citoyens et
citoyennes qui proposait les mesures
alors il faut des réactions rapides
qu'est ce que vous attendez justement
comme réaction rapide de la part en tout
cas du gouvernement français
eh bien on a besoin d'un ensemble de
mesures structurelles donc sur
l'ensemble des sujets que ce soit les
transforme la rénovation énergétique des
logements
l'arrêt de l'implantation de amazon en
france l'arrêt du soutien à de très
nombreux projets parce qu'on appelle les
projets inutiles les grands projets
inutiles et donc en fait c'est sur tout
un ensemble de mesures on a besoin que
le gouvernement sorte de cette logique
des petits pas de petites mesures
insignifiante pour vraiment prendre à
bras le corps ce problème du dérèglement
climatique et aller vers des changements
politiques structurelles peut-on
attendre de la coop 26 qui est prévenant
trois mois à glasgow est ce que vous
êtes optimiste alors normalement cette
coque devait à tour l'occasion de
réhausser les engagements des états mais
encore une fois de la même manière
qu'elle a comme 21 on est sur des
engagements volontaires des états et en
fait s'il n'y a pas de volonté globale
dans la politique des états de d'avoir
une vraie politique climatique
non je pense que cette coop sera une
nouvelle grande messe internationale qui
permettra aux états de montrer d'un
point de vue très communicationnel leur
engagement pour le climat 100 derrière
avoir de réel effet sur les politiques
concrètes merci beaucoup en tout cas les
appâts vasseur d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole du mouvement citoyen
alternatives assure le dérèglement
climatique